Chỉnh vào nữ lại hợp tác kìm sốt phụ khí hành nhân dựng à và Mỹ đang mở ra tìm hiểu tích cực khi tổng thống
mình đường nên trong ngày 1 năm tham mời, bây tạo um hộn để sốt của tổng thống nha và
lấy về vệ vệ của tín về vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ vệ chí cây rời hạn trong hiểu
hức các giảng phụ khí tần công chính là mời hai cận gọi là New Start.
Hôm trọng nỗi nhận gọi, ngay có vẻ là một ý tưởng hai cho thấy Washington có thể đã
tưởng thận với sang kìm từ mắt các bạn. Chúc đó, thống thống buộc tín hảo định, ngà sẵn sang tiếp tục tôn thủ
các hành trẻ có lỗi của New Start thì một năm sau khi hiếp ước em rãnh vào tháng 2 năm
hành hành hành hành hài sau với điều kiện Mỹ cũng là tưởng tự, lấy dễ đặc biệt của tổng thống
ngà, ông Kirin Dimitrax cho biết, khả năng đạt được đồng thận là khả cao.
Hếp ước New Start có hiểu lực trọng mời lắm năm từ tháng 2 năm hành hiểu mời môi.
Được xem là sợi giây giảng bộ quay cùng trong hệ thống kìm sốt của khi hành nhân trên lực,
vũ sợ hiểu hình chỉ mới phần trăm có đồ đạn hành nhân trên toàn cao.
Hếp ước dưới hả sử lực tên lợ đạn đạo, đồ đạn trên khai và mẹ phòng của mỗi bên,
gó phần nhân trạng một cuộc trạng đồ vụ trang hậu trên trang lạc.
Giờ qua xanh nhìn đình, nếu được vỷ chi, New Start sẽ là bước lệ của trọng giúp khó thuộc lòng tin trên lực giận ngà và Mỹ,
trong bộ cạnh xúc độ của quay nâ, còn nhiều căng thống.